wir schauen jetzt auf dem
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach er hat corona erst ist er
gerade frisch geimpft das hat er ja
mitgeteilt karl lauterbach zum vierten
mal und jetzt hat er sich angesteckt am
abend erstmals positiv getestet sein
ministerium hat das vor wenigen stunden
bestätigt in der erklärung können wir
kurz reinschauen pressemitteilung heißt
es der minister habe leichte symptome
nur würde jetzt von zu hause weiter
arbeiten und weiter heißt es da er habe
sich trotz dieser vierten impfung
infiziert und das ministerium ruft dann
auch im letzten satz hier in der
pressemitteilung wider zu dieser vierten
impfung auf und das ist schon
interessant denn für lauterbach konnte
diese infektionen in wahrheit zur
politischen unzeit denn gerade erst hat
er ja mit seinen regierungskollegen
ministerkollegen vor allen dingen mit
justizminister marco buschmann gemeinsam
den plan der ampel regierung für den
corona herbst und winter bekanntgegeben
vorgestellt und da wird schon ja ein
massiver impf druck wieder ausgeübt
selbst auf dreifach geimpfte und die
vierfach impfung als lösung gepriesen
und jetzt eben natürlich auch wieder
eine infektion trotz fürther impfung in
jedem fall aber wünschen wir von bild
hier gute besserung an den minister an
herrn lauterbach
[Musik]